Metro Police making an effort to get out
there and connect with the community the
South Central Area command held a
special event today to build some more
relationships and also curb crime and
other issues across our city Sasha
Loftus joins us live near Twain and
Cambridge with more on today's Community
walk
say they're doing it to really connect
with the community joining Metro Police
to really talk to people about what they
need and as you said therefore curb
crime now the South Central Area command
is known to have a high crime rate which
is why police say they're holding this
event here Metro Representatives
including Sheriff Kevin mcmahill join
County Commissioners organizations and
volunteers to build relationships with
people in this area they're stopping
people on the street along Twain here
and even visiting local businesses to
speak to those around about their needs
this is how you know it's working when
the good people are winning and the bad
people are in their doors with the doors
closed because that's what I want I want
the bad people in their house and I want
the good people walk in the streets of
their dogs I want the good people being
happy and that's what we're going to do
here that's what we're going to do
now Captain Munson said it's also
important to get out here at night and
make Metro's Community presence known
and just really keep everyone a lot
safer back out here live this walk is
set to last around another hour until 5
PM they're walking down the twain
Corridor and then meeting back here at
Dean Peterson Elementary School where
you see their Refreshments all kinds of
things for the volunteers who
participated in this event today
reporting live Sasha Loftus 8 News Now